Five years from now,
each one of us is going to get
a food that is relevant
on his personal biomarkers,
it might be DNA,
it might be physiological data
that you derived from smartwatches,
wearables, like sleeping quality,
HRV, a body battery, etc.
Rachel, thank you for joining me.
How are you?
Wonderful.
Thank you so much.
Where are you calling from right now?
So currently, I'm in Tel Aviv,
the best city in the world.
But, you know, we are spread over
in New York, California, and Tel Aviv.
All over the places.
Definitely.
With Zoom, it's so easy.
Definitely. So, you know,
right now you're running myAir
in the food tech industry.
But you have such a vast experience
with food tech.
Vice president at Teva,
but also experience
with Strauss and with Nestlé
and so many other companies.
So, what I was asking
was tell me a little bit about
your journey into food tech
and why that industry.
And what is so exciting to you
about food technology?
Well, actually, 20 years ago when I
started my own journey
at the food industry,
it was working for Nestlé in Brazil.
I did some consultancy projects
after my MBA in France.
And I discovered the world of food
and fell in love immediately.
But back then, you know,
our KPIs were more about
taking out all the baddies.
You know, we were talking
about quality instead of quantity
and talking about
taking out all the baddies
like oil, salt, sugar.
And when I worked for Nestlé,
for example, I had these KPIs
from the snacks.
So, I needed to make
some healthier snacks.
That was actually
the first generation of food.
The second generation of food
was more about functional food.
Food that works for me,
food that really brings me values
and that was the probiotic words.
For example, we have Activia,
Actimel, the known product
is a very good example for probiotics.
And we now are very familiar
with all the protein bars.
Right.
RX revolution.
Instead of using powders,
just eat it and that's it.
But that was
the second generation of food.
The third generation of food
is actually a personal food
that works for me.
And we call it in myAir, food for mood.
And the consumers are so smart
and they understand
that each one of us is different
and one size does not fit all.
So, each one of us deserve
a different and precise solution
for his own body.
And this is what we are working on
at myAir food tech.
Food for moods,
which based on personalized nutrition.
So, I'd love to talk
about about myAir a lot.
But first, I want to really understand
the industry better
and some of the earned
secrets and insights that you've gained
over working at those various companies.
So, what can you teach me about
the food space in general,
whether it's the innovation side of it,
the marketing, the product side of it,
what insights have you gained
over the years dealing with food
and consumers as a product?
Maybe it's funny, you know,
but my main insights about food came
when I worked for pharmaceuticals.
You know, I was VP
at Teva Pharmaceuticals,
the leading generic pharma company.
And I understood that opioids and drugs
are not a good solution.
And that we are what we eat.
And good health start with what we eat.
And, you know,
if another part of the world
already understood that plants
could be the best medicine
and you know that our body
is a very intelligent creature,
and if you give it the right fuel,
it can heal itself.
You just need to be cautious
to understand your body
and to give it to the right fuel,
which is your food.
So, what we understood
that plants could be that right fuel
because super plants
are the first technology of the world.
Right.
I've been hearing about
these super foods for forever.
Yeah.
So, you know, you say forever
because maybe you are very educated.
But most of us, you know,
started with eating this junk food.
This is what I grew on.
And now, we can understand
that we can be more precise
and learn from plants
and how they deal with nature.
And the very, you know,
new trend in super plants is adaptogens.
Adaptogens come from the word
to adapt to your environment.
Adaptogens are the way that plants
adapt to their environment
and heal themselves.
And the most famous of the adaptogen
in the world is caffeine.
We drink it,
we think that it's a nice flavor,
but that's not enough.
Caffeine actually relates
to our cognitive system
and affect our focus
or [--].
So, what we are doing at myAir,
we actually crafted
and researched formulations
of different adaptogens
coming from super plants,
and each different formulations
created different effect on our mood.
Okay. So, tell me a little bit
about this industry of super foods,
foods for moods.
What's been happening
over the past years
in terms of consumer behavior?
Because you mentioned
that you had different generations
of food tech and innovation
ranging from, you know,
the simple foods that we're used
to eating to then getting
a little bit more personalized
with super foods, and now basically
people can know what foods
are good for them.
And we have companies like DayTwo
23andMe that are giving us insights
into really our genealogy
and what foods will have,
what effect will have on our body.
So, what's happening today in 2020
and what are some interesting
trends that you're observing?
So, actually what is happening
is people understand
that they shouldn't take drugs,
they should take less drugs.
And you know,
transmit themselves to healthier food
and functional foods
that is precise to their own body.
So, that category of food actually
is leading on a huge trend,
which is big data.
You know that professor
Yuval Noah Harari is talking a lot about
the three generations
of consumer decision making.
Right.
They start with religious.
So, it was easy for us
to take a decision by the priest
or the rabbi that helped us to choose
and then moved forward to capitalism.
So, we thought that we have,
you know, all the options.
And now, all of our consumer,
decision making processes
are based on big data.
So, AI actually leverages
our decision making.
And if we think that we choose
a book, for example,
it's not so true because maybe
the book is choosing us.
When I read the Audible,
Audible read me as well.
So, if you compare that
to the food industry,
this is actually what is going
to happen to us.
And five years from now,
each one of us
is going to get a food
that is relevant
on his personal biomarkers.
It might be DNA,
it might be physiological data
that you derived from smartwatches,
wearables, like sleeping quality,
HRV, a body battery, etc.
And of course,
the psychological parameters.
Right.
So, actually we are combining
all that data,
we leverage AI in order
to take decision about everything.
And this is the future of food tech
and this is what we are doing at myAir.
But we are actually focusing
on a very, very big unmet need.
And if you will look around you,
you will see that
most of your colleagues,
friends, family probably
are suffering from chronic stress.
You know that before covid,
the World Health Organization declared
that stress is the chronic silent killer.
It's the epidemic for our era.
And then arrived the very small
other epidemic.
But stress levels just went
you know, higher and higher
since the covid.
And what we understood
is that we can empower the millions
to control their stress
through personalized nutrition.
Because stress, chronic stress
is something that you should manage
as if it was your dietary routine
or your sports routine.
So, actually, we leverage the next trend
of the food industry
with a very big unmet need.
That makes a lot of sense.
So, tell me a little bit about myAir.
What is some of the thought process
that went into that?
Because before myAir,
you were acting as
vice president and executive
at all these fantastic companies
and you decided to venture out
into a company of your own.
And I love understanding
that shift in mindset
and that journey that you take
on you with you.
Yeah.
So, my journey is, as you mentioned,
started from being a corporate girl,
for the last 20 years.
I had a stressful career
as VP marketing at Teva,
the leading generic pharma company.
And as CEO
at this next division at Nestlé,
the leading food corporate.
And as a business leader
and executive manager, and mother
and a caregiver to my parents,
stress has become
a massive burden in my life.
And I tried to manage my stress
through meditation and mindfulness.
But I failed to maintain
a stress less routine.
Until I understood that
there is one thing
that we all love to do
which is eating, of course.
You know that it's really difficult
to change behavior when
there is a friction.
When you try to do something
that is not part of your routine.
But when you combine it into
the regular stuff that you love to do,
like eating, it becomes easy.
So, myAir is actually
a smart food company.
We develop a functional plant-based
nutrition bars,
I can show you in a second,
made with super plants based on research.
Everything is patented at research based
and they're proven to reduce stress.
We leverage big data to tailor them
to the consumer stress effect.
So, imagine that once a month
you get these box into your doorstep
and in the box you're going
to find nutrition bar
that are relevant to your own stress.
So, let's say, you know,
stress has many faces,
and each one of us
deserve his own solution.
So, we conducted a research
with Garmin Health
and we understood that each one of us
has two main stress effects
that are relevant to him.
So, for me, stress affects me
mainly at night, on my sleep
and in the morning, on my focus.
So, those are the bars
that I need to eat.
Okay, and how do you identify that?
How do you identify the things
that you want to improve on?
Yes.
So, we developed an algorithm
with Professor Daniela Kaufer
from Berkeley.
She's the dean of the biological faculty
and a stress researcher
within the last 20 years.
And we actually leverage big data
from physiological markers
and psychological markers.
Because stress is a condition
of mind and body.
So, the physiological data, we take
from a smartwatch.
Do you have a smartwatch
like Garmin or Apple Watch,
something like that?
Yeah.
It's all because
you came from California. Right?
Early adaptor, [--] leader,
you're my target audience.
Amazing. I'm ready to buy.
Yeah.
So you can go to our website,
go to myAir.ai,
do the cognitive assessment.
That's the beginning of the journey.
It's only the first assessment.
And then, we create this engagement
relationship that you keep answer,
we take the data
and we understand what kind of bars
makes you need to eat
and how you can control your stress.
Very, very cool.
So, walk me through some of the process
that I would go as a consumer
if I were to want to take part in myAir.
And I would then love to transition also
the conversation to some of the future,
of what the future holds for us
in food tech in general as well.
Sure.
So, the journey is very easy.
I can assume, you know,
that like most of us,
75% of the population
suffer from chronic stress.
And you go to a website, myAir.ai,
and you fill up
this very short questionnaire,
the test yourself part.
And after a few minutes
you're going to discover
what are the main two stress effects
that are relevant to you.
Everything is research based,
patented and based on a profound
clinical research that we conducted
with the Garmin Health.
So, you are going
to discover your solution,
your personal solution,
and then you are going to order
and then you are going to get the box
and your personal table of usage.
We have consumers
that need to eat one bar
in the morning for focus
or energy or calm
and one bar in the evening
for mass attention
or forgetting to sleep
or to have a deeper quality of sleep.
We have users
that didn't need just only one bar
or one bar per two days,
or something else.
So, everybody gain his own
personal solution.
And then we invite you
to connect your wearable
in order to gain more insights
that are based on physiological data.
And the algorithm
is actually working all the time
and you know, learning never ends.
So, the big data is actually
keep moving on
and keep helping us to get
the best personal box of super plants
for each consumer.
That's so interesting.
So, where is this whole thing headed?
So, it makes perfect sense to me
that things are becoming
more personalized
and we want both take ownership
over what we put into our body.
I just met a fascinating startup
called Feto,
which does personalized capsules
for shaker's for workout's
for whatever we want.
So, there's a lot of really interesting,
very really great.
But there's a lot of interesting
and innovative things happening
in the space.
And I'm really curious about
what is our food experience
is going to be like,
let's say in five, ten years?
What are some
of the big, big shifts
that you are anticipating
in this industry?
So first, the biggest chip,
I think it's going to be
in the area of replacing our drugs
with super plants.
As long as we will move and keep,
you know, growing the trend
of natural ingredients,
and this is a huge trend, you know,
moving to plants, to vegan
and move into clean label,
understand that all these
artificial ingredients are really,
really bad for our body.
And this is going just
to be bigger and bigger
and even covid helped us
you know, to push that.
Another big trend in food
industry is e-commerce.
You know that in covid,
we actually gained
a decades in weeks of progress.
And e-commerce and food boomed
from 11% to 30% in six months
which is unheard of.
So, the e-commerce is going
to help us all in the food industry
to gain more personalization.
Because all the big food corporates
are looking for the best way
to meet their consumer
and to understand him better.
You know that the future of health
is digital health, is prevention.
Each one of us is going to be connected
to his doctor with a device to, you know,
send his own private file to the doctor
and gain his own personal solution
on time, on demand
and even with preventing.
So, the food is going
to help us through that
and going to be a more precise
and based on your own
body physiological needs.
And so, as I mentioned before,
the third generation of food industry
is functional and personalized
and plant based.
That's very, very cool.
And I have to say that
I completely agree with what's going on.
I think that what's interesting for me
is I do a lot of research on food tech
and I'm very conscious as well as
what I put into my body.
And I think that a lot of my generation
is also similar in that regard.
And obviously we know
the integration of all the tools
that we're early adaptors of,
it makes perfect sense,
we're also early adopters
of this mindset.
And that's besides the fact
that I think that supermarkets,
especially in Tel Aviv and Palo Alto
are filled with super foods
and personalized things for us.
What are the side effects of all of this?
So, obviously,
myAirs side effect hopefully
is a population that
has less chronic stress.
What are other side effects
that we can presume regarding
the innovation in food?
So, myAir is, you know,
focusing on one huge unmet need,
which is chronic stress,
but food can help us
you know, with dealing
with other mood conditions as well.
And food for mood industry
is something that is now,
you know, only starting.
But all the big corporates
are investigating that area deeply.
And I'm sure that in the future,
we are going to choose good food
and plants as a source
of cognitive effects as well,
because our body has the right receptors.
And if we just open them
and touch them so
our body can react to that
and our cognitive system
is built for that.
So, we are what we eat
is not just a sentence,
it's truly strong belief.
And I understand as I, you know,
how all the big corporates work
that the wave is going to be huge.
I completely agree.
I think that's inspiring.
And Rachel, I want to thank you
for being so kind with your time,
so generous with your time.
It's been very, very insightful.
And I just love
what you're doing with myAir,
and I'm honestly
going to have to try that
for myself because
I just love food tech
and I love the integration
of artificial intelligence,
the technology with our everyday things,
especially things that we put
into our body.
So, I'm very excited
to check it out for myself.
But before we leave,
I have to ask you
the most important question,
which is three words
that you would use to describe yourself.
Well, I think it would be
with passion to dare and to win.
Wow. I love that. Rachel,
thank you very, very much.
Stay safe. Stay healthy
Thank you so much.
It's been great meeting you.
And I hope,
you know, we will have the chance
to meet face to face as well.
Definitely. Take care.